uh we have kind of an interesting little
wrinkle or substory in the january 6
trump riots we know of course about
hundreds of defendants whose cases are
now
somewhere in the legal system and going
through we've started to see some of the
first sentences several weeks ago we saw
some of the first sentences for the
trump rioters who were charged we now
have another prominent individual who
has been charged this is this is
actually quite interesting
many of you remember infowars this is
alex jones conspiracy website um their
content is banned from a number of
different mainstream platforms including
youtube i think facebook i don't
remember the whole list i think they're
banned from spotify but the show
continues funding comes from supplements
and i think from mike pillow um and
maybe a couple of other brands uh you
have to really look pretty hard for the
show but it is out there and one of
their hosts is a guy named owen schroer
he has been charged and reportedly is
turning himself in today
this is a reuters report which says u.s
prosecutors have charged a texas man who
hosts a talk show tied to the conspiracy
theory website infowars with unlawfully
breaching the u.s capitol grounds during
the january 6 riot by supporters of then
president donald trump owen shroyer
unlawfully entered a restricted area at
the west side of the capitol during the
deadly rampage that interrupted the
formal congressional certification of
biden's victory this is based on what
prosecutors wrote in unsealed court
papers from friday
the hosts
uh he hosts a talk show associated with
infowars called the war room with owen
shroyer it's a daily show
these are misdemeanor charges violent
entry
and disorderly conduct on capitol
grounds
let's look at a video here of owen
shroyer explaining this this he learned
this apparently from his lawyer during a
live broadcast on friday take a look at
this the deal
ladies and gentlemen yeah
a couple hours ago
i was informed by my attorney very
serious
that there is a warrant out for my
arrest
with allegations
involving
january 6th
and i will have to turn myself in
monday morning today
uh there's a lot of questions
some i have answers to some i don't
i'm not going to be getting into more of
this today on the air
smart
and
i plan on
declaring
innocence of these charges right because
i am and so there's some other stuff
going on too
but uh that's the deal
oh boy and so i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna comment any further on this i'm
not gonna take any questions on this
today
but again the questions thing do they
even take questions on this show like
who's gonna force them to answer
questions on this show and i was
informed by my lawyer
that there's a warrant out for my arrest
right now and that i have to turn myself
in by
monday morning
so
uh that's just that
probably shouldn't even be on air right
now but we're gonna go ahead and do a
broadcast anyway
okay and that's probably the correct
instinct he probably should not be on
the air uh if this is if this is what is
going on so there's owen schroer another
uh relatively high profile
um uh target of the investigation has
turned up multiple alleged charges
against him and will follow it these are
misdemeanor charges it is less likely he
will do prison time it is more likely he
has better access to lawyers
particularly if alex jones is going to
help him out but owen schroer
uh turning himself in as far as he is
saying he will do
today
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman